[Musik]
leute herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video mittlerweile weiß nicht was genau
ich mit ihm vorhabe werden wir den
junkies nehmen und in einem musikvideo
von einem youtuber setzen und zwar dass
sandmann video von julien bern ich denke
ihr werdet euch gleich ungefähr
vorstellen können was ich vorhatte
sobald ihr mal ein beispiel ein beispiel
wäre jetzt wenn wir in schänis nehmen
und in die reihe dieser kinder die dann
quasi mit dieser wunsch stimme singen
würden und kannst ja mal was uns
ausgerüstet hier oder zum beispiel wenn
du hier einmal bei diesen typen so
kompost oder ich bin also verliert so
genau was auch schon ne geile idee wir
zum beispiel hast du ja diese partie hat
so ein bisschen stümperhaft zu was hast
du dir also diese kasse gemacht und dann
wie du einfach so daneben stehst und
dann einfach von der sandburg mit dir
selbst weil sie wo du selbst auf sand
einfach so eine figur willst kannst du
so was ich hoffe schon mal vor dass
werden müssen wir quasi mit dir einfach
nur dass zähne in green screen video so
dasteht wie du und ich mache den rest
bei sich einfach so den acht effekten
und daher dass man einfach ganz kurz
durchgehen und vielleicht ein paar
sachen noch brainstorm die wir dann im
nachgang umsetzen können
was hältst du davon wenn sie dein
gesicht bekommt der grünen zufolge die
hauptattraktion wenn nicht kann ich dir
auch so mit dem hintergrund einfach
stehen wir einfach zu stehen oder nicht
sagt er sitzt einfach da sind sich alle
darin sind wurden im bagger so raus
willst wie sondern der scheibe so
vielleicht ja das ging auf
hast du auch die noch sein
ich hab mir schon einmal überlegt damit
das ganze video nur mit deinem gesicht
zu machen aber ich glaube dann zu matsch
der hier auf jeden fall da zwischen der
ja sind kind
in den parteien wird sogar das recht
einfach so gross gelang es gewohnt vor
der weiß ich jetzt aber nicht ob du cool
damit wer ist das wäre natürlich toll
wenn also erstmal zu diesen sand und
dann sieht man zudem schotter nach wir
immer so ein bisschen dreck um kopf weil
du dran sondern woche so ist werde ich
also das war übrigens ist aber willst du
den sand dann animieren oder an wenn du
cool damit ist einfach irgendwie aus
einem topf tabletten ja die lücke dass
man da auch steht
[Musik]
also in meinem kopf ist das mega geil
ich hoffe wir kommen hier waren das ist
eine idee dazu gehen will
vielleicht bei der szene ein bisschen
zurück hier jetzt dass ich hier stehe
rein und dann gucke ich da so laufen
also legal und vor also dass ich mich
erstmal ab und dann in dem andere in
schottland oder muss somit zu einem mob
durch geesthacht für das aus wenn sie
kopfhörer
[Musik]
ja wir haben ja ja dann auch hier wieder
in der leitstelle wo dabei auch zu
zwingen so richtig so egal
dann will ich sagen wir dass ich da mal
rüber in den green screen der schon
vorbereitet ist make up und beginnt
anfang wo diese elektroschocker sie
kennen so nach vorne gehen und ihr mann
hatte eine ermöglicht
[Musik]
das hast du schon mal so dann der
nächste schock der wissentliche damit
ist dann will ich dir den kranken kind
ist acht mal den ganzkörper ist die
richtung
zusammen habe dann dein war kein zimmer
108 durch dann schon lips technik so ein
bisschen probieren 14 wirksamkeit beim
sind die videos eben diesem grund würde
ich direkt sehen dort noch eine zweite
erde auf dem programm
sie kommen nicht nur fans von 50 ja ich
okay interessieren
dann ist der moment der flasche oder
nimmt links technik
der mann hat die nächste chance gewesen
dass ich hier nicht so viele nicht in
hessen leben ja okay das ist wirklich
verkaufen würde
jetzt kommt noch eines in mode muss
sitzen nach dem okay dann haben wir sehr
gut dann vielen dank dass der begriff
world problem und dann könnten die
arbeiten diesen videos die grünen erst
von den mustern erwin flammen und meine
bremsen
die sandstürme budget balanceakt jedes
land kontakt
damit das zeigt dort abstellt ich war
die klassen sandboden ich bin ein genie
und ihr nur erfindungen der süßigkeiten
und die horror geschichte überhaupt
das ist nicht hier erkennt meine melody
und weiß wofür sie steht wenn sie ertönt
ist eines täters jeder küche ich hab den
besten dante starte ich bin eine legende
und wird der anfängt zu rieseln ist euer
tag zu ende
[Musik]
dieser frau die architektin der freundin
lucy freikommen
die kämpften
auch geht
[Musik]
weil man sonst schon
so leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video und wir sind ja schon lange mit
dem video naja wie auch immer willkommen
zu diesem tutorial ich hoffe das video
von eben hat euch gefallen jetzt zeige
ich euch wie ich das genau gemacht habe
zuallererst bin ich in premiere gegangen
und habe dieses komplette musik von joe
quasi einfach neu geschnitten und
umgeschnitten
weil ich natürlich will dass meine
effekt wie du ganz kurz und kompakt und
die besten shots quasi nur kombiniert
hat deswegen habe ich ja vorhin einfach
zusammen den chase die besten ausgesucht
die sich da am coolsten eigenen mit
einer coolen idee und habe die noch mal
neu zusammengeschnitten hat auch die
musik ein bisschen neu
zusammengeschnitten damit die musik
letztendlich nur ein bisschen über eine
minute dauert das habe ich dann alles
mit rechtsklick durch auf direkt
komposition ersetzen enough direkt
reingeschoben da sehen wir auch direkt
mal unsere grundmaterial für den schrott
den wäre es besprechen werden und zwar
da wo jetzt vor dem greenscreen im ufo
kehrt den spiess nämlich gehen und zu
alles habe ich dann mal die kamera
getrackt um dann nachher den schenker
ebenrain setzen zu können so sieht das
dann aus wenn sich das dreidimensional
mit bewegt dann habe ich alles weg
geschnitten was nicht green screen ist
und hat den green screen effekt auf
angewandt damit die grüne vielleicht
eben weg ist habe noch eine kleine
farbkorrektur angewandt damit dass ein
bisschen besser zum film passt wo wir
schon bei farbkorrektur sind sehen wir
dass die tage auf dieser rechten zeit
sich ja so einen grünen scheinhardt auf
der linken seite so ein bisschen den
orangen schein hat das habe ich
verschenkt jetzt auch nach gemacht hier
sieht man jetzt einmal den grünen
scheint auf der rechten seite zum
beispiel bei seinem ellbogen und bei
seinem kopf sieht man hier diesen
orangen schein für alle die es
interessiert dass wir das ein bisschen
kompliziert rein prinzipiell habe ich da
eine schwarze farblichen genommen und
habe davon weil sie cengiz ausgestanzt
das quasi das transparent ist dann
darunter eine weite ebene gesetzt in dem
fall bedeutet weiß dass da der schimmer
also dass da entfällt diese orangene
wurde der grüne schein angewendet wird
aber da wir das nur an diesen ländern
haben wollen halte ich den schenk es
nochmal dupliziert haben den schwarz
gefärbt haben ein bisschen nach rechts
geschoben und ihn extrem stark weich
gezeichnet aber nur also nicht komplett
sondern nur an dieser achse weich
gezeichnet und vertikal dann sieht das
so aus und jetzt in diesem gleichen
bereich wird jetzt eben
die farbe angewandt und ich könnte es
auch blau machen aber natürlich wird das
gar nicht passen deswegen machen wir
rasch und mit den grünen hat sich
genauso verhalten und das macht das
ganze auf jeden fall schon ein gutes
stück realistischer als nur natürlich
noch am meisten auffällt ist dass jetzt
einfach vor zu stehen obwohl er
eigentlich hinter den beiden sein müsste
deswegen habe ich die beiden aus
maskierte das erkläre ich eigentlich so
ziemlich jeden meine videos weil man
eigentlich für so ziemlich alles aus
muskeln braucht aber noch mal ganz gut
ich habe das originalvideo einfach
verdoppelt und überdies gezogen und habe
dann mit diesen masken tool zum beispiel
jetzt hierzu aus maskiert und alles was
dann in dieser maske ist von joe ist
unsichtbar und legt dann quasi über
jingles und das habe ich dann eben bild
für bild nur wenige gemacht für den
kompletten clip auch für die so sieht
das aus wenn man die maske nochmals an
färbt damit er das besser seht und damit
wären wir auch so gut wie fertig das
einzige was jetzt noch auffällt ist
hierbei dass füßen ist so eine halt
abgeschnittene kannte
das liegt daran weil unser green screen
natürlich nicht auf dem boden sondern
nur hinter schränken und deswegen seine
füße nicht im green screen cent einem
anderen job habe ich da seine füße
einfach aus maskiert nochmal machen
wolle damit die auch zu sehen sind was
natürlich ein bisschen viel arbeit ist
die ich mir hier aber einfach gespart
habe dadurch dass ich noch mal so einen
lila nebel über seine füße gelegt habe
und ich das echt sehr sehr gut verdeckt
wird und noch mal so ein bisschen mit
eingebunden werden das original video
und schon haben wir diesen clip fertig
die anderen waren alle ungefähr genauso
aber bisschen anders ihr wisst was ich
meine
und das war es auch schon wieder mit
diesem video erst mal vielen dank an den
lieben philipp den hier vielleicht jetzt
mittlerweile aus einem video von rewe
und auch schon studium war bekennt
vehemenz man diesem video geholfen hat
deswegen zeigt den zugang aus sein name
steht hier einfach jetzt direkt mal
suchen perfekt und auch nochmal vielen
dank an den neben james er sich die zeit
genommen hat mit mir dieses video zu
drehen
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann geht mir
doch den daumen nach oben und abonniert
diesen kanal wenn ihr mich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte und ich würde
sagen dann würden
und ich würde sagen dann ziehen wir uns
im nächsten video und ich würde sagen
dann ziehen wir uns beim nächsten video
wieder
[Musik]